[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
io non volevo essere come mio padre
questo è mariano mariano congo
classe 1962 un pad la giovane fu
l'imprenditore perché anche il
ristorante ma soprattutto non chef
ora si parla tanto di certo non si
capisce niente più la differenza tra
fuoco certo sono tutti share
però non mi non c'è perché perché è a
capo a cap l'ultimo ristorante a capo di
stare con gli altri dipendenti e questi
siamo io e lui
poi ci assomigliamo
debuttano 86
siamo in lui queen qui io sono ero un
bambino abbastanza dirigerò da questa
foto è soprattutto un bambino goloso un
bambino che continua a mangiare e vigo
sembra che la fortuna di un cuoco al
giorno d'oggi e di mangiare sempre tanto
quindi essere goloso mio padre di un
giovane imprenditore quindi il suo tempo
aveva 24 anni ed era impegnato e chiuso
sempre all'interno della cucina io dico
sempre un comico inseguiamo dei topi da
laboratorio chiusi dentro quattro mura
fermi tutto questo giorno è sempre
impegnata per felice forte un altro e io
ero accanto questo nanerottolo che
continuano a mangiare e la mia la mia
tavola ed erano le pentole una più alta
e uno più bassa girate sottosopra non ha
prodotto quaglia in un assenza e lo
guardavo
cucinare intanto
mangiare così mi riteneva di lavoro è
stato bello tranquillo insito nel tempo
poi passa e queste invece si chiama
iniziano a essere completamente diverse
inizia a sentire dentro di te una
mancanza e la mancanza della famiglia la
mancanza di avere un padre un padre
accanto accanto a te è stata insieme
poter condividere da ricondurre il
weekend si lavora il tempo non ce l'ha
mai infatti la mia infanzia vissuta per
la maggior parte con maroni che è stata
in parte hanno fortuna ma dall'altra
parte è stata si è creato questo attrito
tra me e lui doveva prima volta lo
ripetiamo che non sarei mai diventato
come lui non avrei mai fatto le stesse
scelte che ho fatto a lui non avrei mai
e poi mai trascurata da famiglia come ha
fatto lui e questo mi faceva comunque
forse faceva stare male dentro e possono
lo stesso tempo una persona orgogliosa
quindi non è che le parole devono
le parole bisogna starle con infatti
perché altrimenti è troppo facile
medicare
un altro e quindi se una persona
orgogliosa orgogliosa testarda finita la
scuola alberghiera perché avete la
passione non si comanda e la passione
mila trasmessa sono un covo di cognome
corpo non posso far altro
allora ho detto devo capire come
risolvere questo problema
ho deciso di intraprendere stata
completamente il es
sono arrivato da lui eletto papa una
cosa per parlare
vado all'estero tu facessi falso stai
qua da quanto pare dove vai in giro non
voglio fare il mio percorso perché fare
un bel cross internazionale voglio fare
qualcosa che nessun altro ha mai fatto
fino adesso in italia negli ultimi 20
anni i pochi per lo più grande operato
in francia impegni come di diversi libri
ti asiatico che ancora non esisteva
ho preso il biglietto e sono volato con
40 di febbre a melbourne dai disse perto
un mondo un mondo completamente diverso
un mondo nuovo una ristorazione nuova
che non ho mai visto perché ero abituato
nella trattoria di casa a pigoli al
bacalà alla vicentina queste cose quindi
livello di cucina che parla di
espressione che parla di vita che parla
di divertimento che parla nuove lingue
quindi ho la fortuna di apprendere
lingue completamente nuove e diverse
fino ad ogni punto ad un punto
importante di svolta per ora che faceva
due foto questi siamo qui io l'ho
martello e questo sono io in giro per il
mondo berna tasmania qui avrà uno
straniero dalle mamme
e questi sono alcuni degli chef con cui
ho avuto la fortuna di collaborare di
stare insieme e di apparendo le
tantissimo quello che oggi sono giusto
per farvi fare le idee nato a sinistra
abbiamo tre milioni di spagna al giorno
dall ici in basso a sinistra in mano in
alto a destra è un certo di giapponese a
tokyo forse dall'esperienza più
importante e mi ha insegnato è però a
tokyo per solamente a roppongi in basso
a destra sempre in australia il centro
assegna tre comuni ora più cari amici
che era suo tempo era il set
sopra di lei
passiamo al papero andiamo fuori dalla
cucina ovviamente quando quando qualcuno
è giovane quando qualcuno è orgoglioso
ha una percentuale forte dettate
dall'inesperienza è dettata anche dalla
passione di rischio di una persona per i
sì e io e un'altra passione
accanto alla cucina da sempre da quando
avevo tre anni della moto so se mi
vedete sono terzo non c'è un primo in
questo video posizionamento di sempre
quindi arrivato secondo terzo però da
fine piccolo coltivato questa passione
ma la passione come si parlava prima una
passione di pancia un qualcosa che senti
dentro i fatti ris che ci cavola ma
anche tutte le vetrine a vedere le moto
ha provata formule mi prendi una
minimoto vuole correre in molti mi
dicevano non ho pensato a qualcosa va
troppo in sala ovale che va bene una
casa e ti infinito questa passione
questa passione però ultimata nel tempo
a 16 anni ha iniziato ad essere un
lavoro quindi l'anno
ci sono anche diventati effettivamente
un lavoro sono limitato un pilota
professionista dei 16 anni a 19 anni
ovviamente poi ho chiuso la mia carriera
perché
l'inter azionari primo bisogna bisogna
ovviamente pensare a qualcos'altro
perché se sei in eccellenza devi essere
un eccellenza e di spazio all'interno
del mondo del motociclismo anche sembra
cose così che coltivo anche oggi
ovviamente
veramente poco che poi un po le vite il
mite l'inter ma per caso in un giorno
riflettendo detto ma il rischio voi
avete presente cosa è la staccata
all'interno allegramente ciclistica ok e
la frenata e la frenata che divide il
pilota e miglior pilota da che sarà il
futuro valentino rossi e da un pilota
ovviamente qualunque io quando arrivavo
a questa staccate a trani 300 200 e 100
metri staccavo a 120 non staccano di
centro e quindi questo non mi permetteva
di essere patrimonio è successa una cosa
completamente diverso invece nella mia
vita
nella mia quotidianità nel mio lavoro
nella mia professione in quello dello
chef che di fronte
quando ho sentito dentro che era il
momento e ho tirato una staccata una
staccata fortissima che mi ha riportato
in vita quindi direttamente dal giappone
sono volato in italia e io ho deciso che
era il momento di esaminare tutte le
conoscenze
ho fatto tutto il background che anche
mio padre mi ha trasmesso nel tempo e di
aprire finalmente il mio ristorante in
quel paesino di diecimila anime che si
sa del ristorante che dopo un anno e ha
la possibilità di diventare il giovane
chef stellato in italia
[Musica]
perché siamo normalmente non sono così è
che una foto solo dell'apparizione della
williams è stato qualcosa che ha
cambiato totalmente la mia vita anche
perché la giovane questo sono ancora
giovanotto forse non più giovane musei
lì avevo 25 anni quindi molto molto
giovane e era cambiato la percezione da
parte delle persone che si avvicinavano
al mio ristorante da un giovane pazzo a
un giornale che effettivamente era stato
riconosciuto come non interessi del
nostro non italiana
ma torniamo da mariano un utile di segna
mitiche questo è trasmesso da sempre da
quando ho iniziato a comprendere è
iniziato a parlare un esito a camminare
era quello di svelare sempre e comunque
tutti era un'ossessione
ed è ancora per lui la professione
quando vai io devo entrare riso per
tutti cioè se hanno fatto il giro del
ristorante del bar dei bagni dappertutto
sui trattori
che mai sono stato a tutti sia sotto
tutti e questa è una cosa che mi ha
sempre accompagnato non qualcosa che
però nel demo pesa ma perché ovviamente
se un bambino non capisci vuole andare
via
trovati fatale indietro e altissimo va a
salutare tutti qua ma perché in ogni
volta devo salutare tutti quanti e e per
cui nasce una domanda una domanda che vi
voglio fare poi sapete qual è la paura
seconda solamente alla morte
vediamo in aziende se c'è qualcuno gli
urla e seconda paura no è quella di
essere giudicati e lì ho capito qualcosa
ho capito un ragionamento nella sua
testa e il perché io costantemente non
volevo essere come mariano perché io ho
basato quello che io sono oggi perché
non voglio e non è la possibilità di e
di influenzare quello che sono
a giudizio di qualcun altro quando
invece mio padre è cresciuto nel tempo
ha fatto quello che ha fatto
mi ha insegnato quello che mi ha
insegnato però sempre con l'ansia con la
paura che qualcuno potesse dire qualcosa
e questo si riflette nella famiglia se
riflesso appunto in me è la stessa cosa
anche nella cucina
io faccio una cucina libera piace non
piace a me non è un problema
ci vuole un ristorante piuttosto che in
un altro però anche lui cucina quello
che gli altri gli impongono di cucinare
e se dicevo fare qualcosa di diverso
no perché gli altri non piace e questa è
stata la vera differenza che c'è
allontanato in quel frangente in quel
momento perché volevo essere libero e
lou reed a dirmi no attendo che gli
altri ti giudicano
lo rifai e che li porta due esempi ad
esempio che sono sono abbastanza chiare
allora questo è il mio primo ristorante
il primo ristorante aperto appunto nel
2011 l'ho aperto da solo
l'ho aperto senza grandi aiuti sono
partito ho fatto il mutuo eccetera e
defunta non lo so di essere adatto al
mio padre dentro lo sai una cosa io
voglio che le persone che vengono
all'interno dei miei ristorando vengono
per come sono fatto io perché sono io e
per la cucina che io propongo non per
quello che loro vogliono e loro si
aspettano quindi sai una cosa io tolgo
la tovaglia no ma cosa fai
mi fa sei scemo ma ti fa la leggiamo
però ristorante e in più è anche
chiudere dopo un mese
altrove a me però almeno fatto quello
che vogliono
sono orgoglioso sono testardo e lasciami
fare quello che voglio vabbé lanciate in
alto il costume dice vabbè ma sono nella
mia ma non ho quasi quasi mi va meglio e
invece no e invece no nel fitto una nota
la stella i clienti si lamentavano certi
clienti arrivano molte sedie scomode per
cucina che fai perché il cibo ma le cose
si sistemano poi le cose cambiano ma non
pretendere tutto quanto subito da uno
che a 25 anni perché lo pretende dov'è
il senso di questo è e così così è
successo quindi come sulla stella le
cose in funzionare in maniera diretta la
clientela diventato anche intera fissa
chi entrava il ristorante entra per
trovare lorenzo con non entrava per
trovare quello che loro volevano e
lonigo stavano o che esigevano da parte
di un ristorante e quindi ci sarà de
cambiato e in cinque anni e mezzo ha
fatto tre restyling quindi migliorato il
comfort è diventato più più coccolo più
caldo le luci era perfetta e
arriverebbero non c'era più
tutti dettagli che fanno di un grande
ristorante un posto dove andare ed è
perfetto di sentirsi coccolati dove
sentirsi a casa
questo è l'ultimo mio ultimo ristorante
bio ristorante perché poi mi sono
appunto spostata dopo ci viene in mente
andiamo ad un altro esempio sempre molto
chiaro questo è lo mangio la
barbabietola lo mangiano anitona è un
piatto che fatto la storia del mio
ristorante a chi lo ha fatto assaggiare
per primo l'ho preso gli ho detto
assaggio a questo piatto cosa ne pensi
questo è una maggiore a barbabietola c'è
la base
eravamo insistenza un nodino di di
barbabietola degenti martinitt e le
barbabietole affumicate cosa sarà un
antipasto mi fa bene massimo dessert e
papà tranquilli non ti preoccupare
grazie comunque ci vediamo come un
prossimamente arriva subito dopo una
settimana un video gastronomico però fai
che se santos uno dei più grandi critici
gastronomici per farvi un'idea perché
conoscere l'astronomia lui ha scoperto
ferrara nodari hubble è arrivato
all'inter nel mio ristorante il porto
questo piatto tipico massaggio è no sia
estesa ostia e super quello di essere un
genio come se lo paga la ditta di
maschili
e invece no invece è tutto è cambiato
tant'è che mi ha chiamato tutti ne
scrive non alicante bene sa chi e
tecniche tiene su un premio e mi ha dato
il premio alla carriera 25 anni e di un
po confuso
[Musica]
e come potete vedere la persona che ho
preso è sempre come esempio con un
modello effettivamente da evitare e
infine colui che mi ha permesso di
essere quello che sono oggi non si fa
abbastanza affermato che vuole crescere
ancora che però ha un'attività di quasi
800 metri quadri a vicenza che ha più di
25 dipendenti tutti i giovanissimi con
un sacco di voglia di fare che seguono e
mi esempio come tenute d'élite per come
scintilla ogni giorno e quindi oggi in
un momento in cui si parla sempre di
gastronomia separa di piatti io ho detto
non voglio andare
questa domanda su importante come questa
come oggi essere qui con voi e parlare
sempre delle identità la filosofia
questo fenomeno no ho detto no non
vogliono perché ormai siamo stanchi di
queste cose qui voi invece parlare
appunto
di maria ma visto il minimo paolo gallo
mariano io e lui però provincia perché
volevo ringraziare di cuore
poi lui con che con i suoi sbagli con i
suoi ruoli tante volte
non premeditati ha fatto di me una
persona migliore
quindi grazie grazie a maria ma è grazie
a tutti quanti voi per oggi
[Musica]
riteniamo il nostro e poi ovviamente
ricordo le stanno in maglietta uomo e
come ogni volta dall'altra parte
quindi raccomando non seguiamo sulla
direzione cerchiamo anche me c'è sempre
al futuro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]